my kids have pulled a Freaky Friday move on
my daughter used to be defiant and give me a hard time during lessons
and my son used to be an angel
and now they have flip flop
don't get me wrong I'm glad I'm not battling them both at the same time
but what is going on for the last few days
my son has just been complaining that everything is just too hard
he's too tired and he doesn't wanna do anything
I'm trying to show him a little Grace because he is younger doing harder work
but we've gotta work on that perseverance in that grade
cause we're not gonna give up and not do something just because it's hard
and quite honestly it's not even really that hard for him
he just doesn't wanna try
last year in kindergarten
everything was just so easy for him
so this is a little bit more challenging
yeah I know you're gonna ask what do you do in moments like that
first I always give him a break
because learning is not gonna happen when he shut down like that
if the weather is reasonable
we usually go outside because outside fixes everything
or I give him a snack and some time alone
when he's calm down
we talk about why he responded that way and what we could do differently
so we're always gonna come back to that activity either today or tomorrow
but it's going to get done
because we don't quit just because it's hard